keep an eye out for sandworks because
it's time to delve into the hidden
history of one of sci-fi's most popular
franchises from the classic book series
to the movie adaptations this is the
Untold Truth of Doom
between the coastal town of Florence
Oregon and the Pacific Ocean are the
Oregon dunes massive Sandhills that in
the 1950s the U.S department of
Agriculture discovered were actually
moving they attempted to use certain
breeds of grasses to stabilize and calm
the dunes before they could continue to
grow move and as Frank Herbert wrote to
his literary agent swallow whole cities
lakes rivers and highways having
published a few successful science
fiction novels already Herbert traveled
to Florence in 1957 to explore this
bizarre scientific phenomenon and to
write an article that piece was never
completed but the concepts of precious
natural resources monstrous sand dunes
and the Mysteries that may lay within
led to Dune after five years of research
and writing Herbert published Dune world
and the prophet of Dune in serial form
in analog Magazine from 1963 to 1965.
the author then compiled it into a
single volume novel Doom which was
published by technical book publisher
Chilton books in August 1965 after more
than 20 other Publishers rejected it
Dune was published in 1965 but it didn't
hit the big screen until
1984. for almost that entire span of 20
years efforts were underway to adapt the
book in 1971 appjack International best
known for the Planet of the Apes movies
acquired the movie rights and offered
the director's chair to David lean the
legendary British filmmaker behind
another desert based movie Lawrence of
Arabia lean past as did British director
Charles Jarrett while a director was
sought out screenwriters worked on the
script and production plans were put
into place but it all fell apart when
abject head Arthur P Jacobs died in
1973. appjack sold the rights to Dune to
a group of French investors who hired
avant-garde film and the optical
director Alejandro jordanovsky as
director while he'd only directed three
full-length films at that point he
definitely had the enthusiasm and
ambition necessary to direct Dune and
then some as detailed in the fascinating
2013 documentary jarowski's Dune the
director planned to make a 14-hour movie
with a Dreamcast including Orson Welles
Mick Jagger Salvador Dali and a
soundtrack provided by Pink Floyd to
nail down the production design
jodorovsky consulted such Innovative
artists as Mobius and H.R Giger he also
wanted to depict the melange the spice
as a magical blue sponge and completely
changed the ending of the novel when
that project died the rights were sold
to producer Dino De Laurentiis who hired
Ridley Scott to direct he dropped out
because as he related in a 1999
biography he was ready to film the movie
immediately but it was going to take at
least two and a half more years of
pre-production ultimately the gig went
to then cult movie icon David Lynch what
the hell Dune finally started being
committed to film in 1983 at Churubusco
studios in Mexico City that location was
chosen in part because it was adjacent
to large swaths of desert that could
stand in for the planet Iraqis and
because the Mexican economy was such
that it would cost Universal Pictures
far less to shoot the movie there than
would have cost in the U.S shooting in
La the producer estimates could have
bumped the Dune price tag to 75 million
dollars It ultimately cost about 40
million dollars and filmmakers made sure
that every penny counted to create the
intricate worlds of Frank Herbert's
novel one of the biggest film Crews of
all time was assembled 900 workers
toiled for months to build 70 sets on
eight sound stages more than 200 people
alone had to clean three square miles of
desert down on their hands in knees no
less of scorpions snakes and cactuses to
replicate the lifeless surface of
arrakis
Universal hoped Dune would be the next
Star Wars but while it was certainly as
imaginative and ambitious as George
Lucas's epic it ended up being a huge
disaster critics absolutely hated it
Roger Ebert said Dune was quote a real
mess an incomprehensible
ugly unstructured pointless Excursion
into the Mercure Realms of one of the
most confusing screenplays of all time
David Lynch's Dune lacked the broad
appeal and fun of more popular sci-fi
like Star Wars and Universal knew it on
some level before the movie was released
Distributing hundreds of thousands of
vocabulary guides to movie theaters in
order to familiarize audiences with the
dense world of Dune settings characters
and words the guides didn't help much It
ultimately earned just 30 million
dollars at the box office not even
clearing its 40 million dollar budget as
a result Frank Herbert's other dude
books were never adapted for the big
screen
Dune and its sequels make for a
thoughtful sprawling imaginative sci-fi
epic and the books were popular in the
60s and 70s which can mean only one
thing it inspired a lot of progressive
rock in 1977 Jazz keyboardist David
Matthews released Dune inspired by the
books in 1979 experimental German
electronic music composer and tangerine
dream member Klaus Schultz released Doom
an album of the music inspired by the
novel that same year French Electronica
Pioneer Bernard scheiner under the name
Z release date Dune themed album called
visions of Dune around the time of the
film's release Iron Maiden included the
song to tame land on its 1983 album
peace of mind having changed the song
from its original title of Dune because
Herbert wouldn't give permission in 1999
German metal band Gollum released the
Dune themed concept album the second
moon
Lynch estimated that his shooting script
would translate to a running time of
about three hours but once it was filmed
edited and effects were added in Dune
wound up being well over four seeing
that as completely unmarketable
Universal ordered Lynch to cut a bunch
of scenes and streamline the plot
because of all that unused footage
rumors have persisted for more than 30
years that there's a special Lynch
curated director's cut there isn't
Universal has approached Lynch but his
displeasure and disappointment in the
film has kept him from returning to
Cobble together another version there is
however a three-hour version of Dune
with extra scenes added in assembled
without Lynch's involvement for
television broadcast Lynch was so upset
that he demanded his name taken off the
credits for this version replaced with
the standard director pseudonym of Alan
Smithy with the fake name Judas Booth
subbed in for screenwriter so named
because Universal betrayed Lynch like
Judas did to Jesus and also killed the
movie like John Wilkes Booth to Abraham
Lincoln in a a career filled with weird
challenging movies and zero Bonafide box
office hits Dune is about the only
project that writer director David Lynch
says he truly wishes he hadn't made in
fact he says it even soiled him as an
artist Lynch later told extrovert that
he only has himself to blame he said I
probably shouldn't have done that
picture but I saw tons and tons of
possibilities for things I loved and
this was the structure to do them in
there was so much room to create a world
far off in the control rooms of spice
gas
traveling
without moving
after years of research and writing
Frank Herbert completed two short
science fiction novels Dune World in
1963 and the prophet of Dune in 1965.
these stories were published in
serialized form in analog magazine one
of the major outlets for genre stories
in the mid 20th century at the time
short stories dominated sci-fi because
according to the guardian that's what
Publishers thought readers wanted that's
probably a big reason why Dune was
rejected by more than 20 Publishers
before it found a champion in Chilton to
improve that there was a market not just
for long-form science fiction but
high-end Science Fiction with literary
merit June is one of the first modern
day sci-fi epics and was thusly rewarded
capturing the inaugural nebula Award for
best novel consumers responded in a big
way to Dune and its descendants it's
still a consistent seller and is one of
the most purchased sci-fi books in
history while sequel Children of Dune
went down as the first novel in the
genre to become a best seller in
hardback form
pre-production on the 1984 Dune
including the months it took writer
director David Lynch to adapt Frank
Herbert's novel into a screenplay took a
very long time and filmmakers wanted to
make sure they cast the perfect
performers to portray the potentially
lucrative franchises already well-known
characters Glenn Close turned down the
role of Jessica believing that the
character was a cliche of a helpless
woman Aldo Rey was initially cast as
Gurnee halleck and reported to the set
but was soon dismissed and replaced by
Patrick Stewart Kenneth Rana auditioned
for the lead role Apollo tradies but
lost out to newcomer Kyle McLaughlin
Brad is future partner Helena Bon Carter
was also merely a part of the Dune cast
she landed the role of Princess iRulu
but due to a scheduling conflict On A
Room With a View she had to quit the
Sci-Fi epic leaving the door open for
Virginia Madsen to take over
although Dune is set among sophisticated
planets in the distant future the
entertainment options of its residents
have a distinctively ancient and rustic
sensibility Kearney Hallock is a major
figure in the life of Paula trades a
warrior teacher and Ally who love to
perform old Minstrel style ballads to
entertain guests and Associates all
while accompanying himself on a long
nine-stringed instrument called balliset
something of a cross between a guitar
and a zither it provided enough music to
help halleck emphasize his Proverbs
scripture readings and lyrics in the
1984 film version of Dune Patrick
Stewart plays halek and the bellisette
it was mentioned by name in Frank
Herbert's original Dune novel but
filmmakers took a real although obscure
Earth instrument and painted it gold the
balance set is actually a Chapman Stick
a fretboard-based elaborately strung
strummable wooden instrument invented by
musician Emmett Chapman in 1985 Chapman
released parallel Galaxy an album of
Chapman Stick compositions which
includes backyard heard in the Allen
Smithy cut of the Dune movie with Stuart
miming playing to Chapman's recording
at the time that Dune was filmed in the
early 1980s Sean Young was one of the
biggest new stars in Hollywood thanks to
prominent roles in the hit comedy
stripes and the sci-fi classic Blade
Runner she signed on to play Chinese
kinds the enchanting freeminine Doom but
she nearly missed out on the role
according to the making of Dune Young's
agency set up a meeting in New York City
with director David Lynch and producer
Rafaela DiLaurentis but then forgot to
tell young about it on the day was
scheduled she hopped a flight to
California to go meet about another film
meanwhile Lynch and delaurentis missed
their flight to the West Coast because
they'd been waiting around for no show
young the actor director and producer
all wound up on the same plane and De
Laurentiis asked a flight attendant if
young whom she'd never met or seen was
an actor the worker reportedly said she
is her name is Sean Young De Laurentiis
confronted young telling her that the
agency said she refused the audition
which simply wasn't true the trio
cleared the air over drinks he recalled
I sit with her and David and we all
start drinking champagne by the time we
arrived in La we were drunk young got
the part of course
for the role of House of tradies
patriarch Duke Leto of tradies Dune
writer director David Lynch cast German
actor Jurgen brucknow the breakout star
of the 1981 World War II submarine
Thriller Das boat according to the
making of Dune the last scene procknow
had to film was a drug-induced nightmare
sequence in which he lays unconscious on
a stretcher while the wicked Baron
harkonen played by Kenneth McMillan
crudely shoves his fingers into a facial
wound expelling spooky green gas to
bring this concept to life the Dune
special effects team created a fake
cheek out of rubber and makeup stuck it
to proctner's face and attached a tube
that ran behind the actor's ear and onto
the stretcher off-camera a tech would
pump green smoke into the device that
would plume out when MacMillan prodded
it the crew tested the effect on a dummy
and proc now before cameras rolled when
it came time to film MacMillan did what
he was supposed to do sticking his
fingers into the wound and the smoke
came out something had gone wrong
however because proc now ran off the set
clutching his face an investigation
revealed that the device had
malfunctioned it hadn't been properly
sealed and hot smoke from a test had
built up inside the fake cheek before
McMillan tore it open resulting in near
molten Goose spilling onto prochnow's
face he suffered first and second degree
burns in the accident
David Lynch's Dune was obviously
supposed to be a franchise starter a new
blockbuster series to rival other sci-fi
Brands like Star Wars and Star Trek its
success was so assured that before the
film's theatrical release in 1984 star
Kyle McLaughlin signed a contract to
appear in four more films in the Dune
Cinematic Universe Virginia Madsen who
landed the small role of Princess irulin
told the Kevin Pollock chat show that
she'd signed a deal to reprise the role
in two more films she recalled they
thought they were gonna make Star Wars
for grown-ups and it didn't work out
that way when Dune was greeted with
critical shrugs and less than huge
numbers at the box office a 30 million
total run against a 40 million budget
plans for more movies were canceled
Dunes screenwriter director David Lynch
was already deep into the screenplay for
the next movie in the series based on
Frank Herbert's Dune Messiah which was
subsequently abandoned muadib had become
the hand of God
fulfilling the fremin prophecy rather
than seek out an orchestral composer to
create and conduct the score for the
original Dune film from 1984. filmmakers
used rock band Toto to Source the
movie's spooky futuristic synth-based
music the group consisting of successful
Los Angeles session musicians was just
coming off a career Peak winning the
album of the Year Grammy Award in 1983
for Toto 4 which included the Smash Hits
Rosanna and Africa the band was at a
Crossroads when it came time to record
the Dune music with singer Bobby Kimball
having just departed and the group
deciding to score David Lynch's sci-fi
adaptation instead of another gig it had
been offered recording the soundtrack to
Footloose nevertheless the album flopped
released back to back with Toto's fifth
studio album isolation the Dune
soundtrack tanked almost as hard as the
movie did peaking at number 168 on the
billboard album chart and soon falling
out of print for decades according to
vintage guitar members of the group saw
the film at its Premiere and called it a
turkey and privately took to referring
to the movie as Doom
regardless of the film's lackluster
performance the Dune franchise continued
to gather more fans with each passing
year the franchise itself also grew with
a well-received mini-series airing on
the Sci-Fi channel in 2003 and Herbert's
son Brian Herbert writing more
best-selling Dunes Sequel and prequel
novels along with Kevin J Anderson by
2008 Hollywood once again saw Dune as a
hot property with a lot of commercial
potential Paramount announced plans for
a new version of the first novel and
hired Peter Berg the director of Hancock
and Battleship to direct a year later
Berg dropped out and Pierre Morrell of
Taken Fame replaced him but the studio
called the whole thing off in March
2011. once again Dune refused to die in
2016 legendary entertainment restarted
the project again Denise Villeneuve the
oscar-nominated director of arrival and
Blade Runner 2049 signed on to direct a
new adaptation of Frank Herbert's
original novel from 1965 with a budget
reportedly around 200 million dollars it
ranks among the most expensive
undertakings in Hollywood history and
that's just the beginning as the project
was planned from the start to be split
into two movies
Madsen claimed that filmmakers had
attempted to make Star Wars for
grown-ups that's the exact same approach
that writer director genevil NIV took
when he set out to bring Dune to the
screen again more than three decades
after that ill-fated attempt philnev
told fandom the ambition is to do the
Star Wars movie I never saw in a way
it's Star Wars for adults ironically
Star Wars began as a riff on Doom George
Lucas's first drafts of the script that
would become 1977 Star Wars A New Hope
contained fighting Bloodlines and a
princess who guarded not the plans for a
death star but something called Aura
spice the cinematographer on his new
Dune films Greg Frazier who had the same
job on the Star Wars spin-off Rogue one
a film Villeneuve enjoyed Dune is a
passion project for the director who
told press that in adapting the work
correctly he dealt quote with the
pressure of the dreams he had as a
teenager picturing the world of Dune in
his head as he read Frank Herbert's
novel still when Warner Brothers wanted
him to direct he agreed to do so if two
conditions were met do Moon had to be
split into two films and the crew would
film The Iraqis scenes in a real desert
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]